now ukraine says it's facing fuel
shortages as russian forces destroy
their country's oil and gas
infrastructure fuel is running low in
many areas including kiev and the negro
some regions are restricting purchases
to 10 litres of gas at a time president
zielenski has vowed to prevent shortages
but admits it's a difficult task more so
after a key refinery was hit by a
russian missile
for more let's bring in lana zechar who
is an advisor to the minister of energy
in ukraine she joins us from kiev hello
and welcome to dw so ukraine needs fuel
to move people goods and military gear
across the country but does that have
enough to make that happen
hello we are in a situation where we
have a shortage due to missile attack on
our own refinery
so now after this attack we need to
replace this shortage with an import and
this is also a challenge for us because
odessa which used to be our main port
and enter a gate for the fuel is now
blocked by russian vessels
military vessels and on the
north we have
of course bella russia where we also
used to consume some fuel and diesel in
particular
and all to these routes now are
completely out of
possible supply
so that's why we need to reroute our
supply chains and to get fuel from
our neighbors and here we of course also
have a number of logistic issues and
problems
okay i mean knowing all of these
challenges and uh the possible logistic
problems still president zielenski and
also ukraine's economy minister said
that fuel shortages will be eliminated
within a week or two
how does the government intend to tackle
the problem
there are a few dimension how the
government is going to tackle this
problem of course we very much rely on
the supplies from our neighbors as i
just mentioned
and we made everything possible in order
to supply this gasoline and diesel to
ukraine
it will take some time to deliver it to
the consumers but we hope that in a week
time we will manage to do this and the
second of course challenge is the
necessity to raise prices because we are
any more don't have a possibility to
supply from the national refinery that's
why the government will have to increase
prices and to change the formula of
price
as you also mentioned earlier ukraine's
energy supply infrastructure is a
constant target of russian strikes
what is the key plan here you mentioned
a couple earlier but what is the key
plan here to secure these vital
pipelines
although there definitely are challenges
expected in doing so
you know that pipelines especially gas
pipelines that's the most secure place
in kiev or in ukraine in particular
because despite the war and despite this
incredible
losses in our infrastructure our gas
transportation system still remains the
most secure place in ukraine
they don't target any particular
pipeline especially those whose which
supplies gas to europe
as for the rest of our transportation
system especially
refineries and
diesel supplies and diesel warehouses
that's the most dangerous places and we
don't keep any more particular
amounts of gasoline or diesel in any
warehouse because they target them and
they destroyed them
okay now you have been very critical of
the eu's energy relations with russia
what is your main concern of how it
affects the ongoing war in ukraine
europe is the main consumer of russia
energy products
and that's
in the particular and now circumstances
current circumstances
is the main source of finances to the
work
so that's why we are very critical for
this source of financing the war and we
do believe that europe has the chance to
stop
uh this
financial flaws and to keep all the
money at least in europe till
russia will come back to the normal
situation and to the normal relations i
still do believe that this is possible
and that iranian model which was
introduced
to iran
can work with russia as well and that's
why we continue to work with european
politicians and persuade them that
russia will not be in the position to
shut down
guest supplies because they physically
cannot keep all this amount of gas in
russia so they will continue to supply
even if russia if even if europe
introduced this escrow account and will
keep money on the account
okay lana zakar from the ministry of
energy in ukraine thank you
thank you
you